we will now apply our multinomial
formula for counting the number of
partitions to solve the following
probability problem we have a standard
52-card deck which we deal to four
persons each person gets 13 cards as for
example in bridge what is the
probability that each person gets
exactly one ace well before we start as
always we will need a probability model
we deal the cards
fairly and this is going to be our model
but we still need to interpret our
statements to give this interpretation
let us first think of the outcomes of
the experiment what are the possible
outcomes and outcome of this experiment
is a partition of the fifty-two cards
into the four persons so that each
person gets exactly 13 cards our
statement about dealing the cards fairly
will be an assumption that all
partitions are equally likely
okay so since all partitions all
outcomes of the experiment are equally
likely this means that we can solve a
probability question by Counting we need
to count the number of elements of our
sample space the number of possible
outcomes and then count the number of
outcomes that make the event of interest
to occur let us start with the number of
elements of the sample space this is the
problem that we just dealt with a little
while ago the number of outcomes the
number of partitions of 52 items by into
four persons where we give thirteen
cards to person one thirteen cards to
person two thirteen cards to person
three and thirteen cards to person for
the number of possible ways of doing
this is equal to this multinomial
coefficient so now let us count the
number of outcomes that belong to the
event of interest namely the outcomes
were where each person gets an ace we
think of the process of constructing
such an outcome as a multi-stage process
and we count the number of choices that
we have at each stage the process is as
follows we first distribute the four
aces we take the ace of spades and give
it to one person in how many ways can we
do it we can do it in four ways then we
take the next ace the next ace must be
given to a different person and so at
that stage we have three different
choices about whom to give that ace to
then we consider the next ace at this
point two persons already have aces so
we have two available choices for who
can get the next ace and finally for the
last ace we do not have any choice we
give it to the only remaining person who
doesn't yet have an ace having
distributed the four aces then we need
to somehow distribute the remaining 48
cards to the four people but we can do
that in any way we want
so all we need to do is to
partition the 48 cards into four subsets
of given cardinalities and this can done
by a number of ways which is the number
of such partitions we have already found
what that number is and it is this
particular multinomial coefficient so
the number of ways that we can
distribute the cards so that each person
gets an A is according to the counting
principle is going to be the number of
ways that we can distribute the aces
times the number of ways that we can
distribute the remaining cards the
product of this number gives us the
count gives us the cardinality of the
event of interest we also have the
cardinality of the sample space so the
desired probability can be found by
dividing these two numbers and the final
answer takes this form let us now look
at the same problem but in a different
way
probability problems can often be solved
in multiple ways and some can be faster
than others so we want to look for a
smarter solution that perhaps will get
us in a faster way to the desired answer
we will use the following trick we will
think about a very specific way of
dealing the currents which is the
following we take the 52 cards the card
deck and stack it so that the four aces
are at the top so they are first and
then we deal those cards to the players
as follows we think of each player
having 13 slots of his own and the cards
will be placed randomly into the
different slots so we can do this one
card at a time starting from the top we
take the first ace and send it to a
random location then we will take the
second ace and it to a random location
and so on what we want to calculate
is the probability that the four aces we
end up in locations or in slots that are
associated with different persons so let
us calculate this probability the first
ace can go anywhere it doesn't matter
for the second ace it has 51 slots to
choose from it's 51 because we started
with 52 but one slot has already been
taken by that particular ace so for the
ace of hearts we have 51 slots that it
can go to and out of those 51 we have 39
of them that belong to people who do not
yet have an ace so this is the
probability that the ace of hearts gets
placed into a slot that belongs to a
person who is different than the person
who got the second the first ace now let
us consider this ace what is the
probability that this ace will get into
a slot which belongs to either this
person or that person it has 26 slots in
which this desired event is going to
happen and it's 26 out of the 50
available slots finally let us consider
this ace so having placed that ace and
assuming that it goes to a different
person what is the probability now that
this ace is going to go to this person
who doesn't yet have one the probability
of this happening is the number of slots
associated with that person which is
equal to 13 divided by the number of
slots that this card can choose from and
the number of slots is 52 - the three
slots that have already been taken
so it's 49 and so this is the answer to
our problem this expression looks very
different from the expression that we
derived a little earlier but you can do
the algebra the arithmetic simplify the
answer and you will
verify that indeed it's exactly the same
answer and case you're curious the
numerical value turns out to be point
105 so there is about 10% that when you
deal the cards in bridge each one of the
players is going to end up by half
having exactly one ace so this was a
faster way of getting to the answer to
our problem compared to the previous one
but it raises a legitimate question is
the way that we dealt the cards by
putting the aces on top and then dealing
them is that way a fair way of dealing
the cards is it true that with this way
of dealing the cards all partitions are
equally likely it turns out that this is
indeed the case but it does require a
bit of thinking maybe you can see it
intuitively that this is the case but if
not then it is something that one can
prove it can be proved formally as
follows one first needs to check that
all permutations that is all possible
allocations of cards into slots are
equally likely and because of this one
can then argue that any possible
partition in two subsets of 12 is also
equally likely so this is an equivalent
way of dealing the cards to the one that
we considered earlier which was that
every partition is equally likely
therefore we did indeed solve the same
problem and so this is a legitimate
alternative way of getting to the answer
and of course it's reassuring to check
that this numerical expression agrees
with a numerical expression we had
derived earlier